container optimized OS is an operating
system image for your compute engine VMs
that is optimized for running docker
containers and as Google's recommended
operating system for running containers
on Google cloud platform on this episode
of Google cloud labs we'll review what
you'll learn in this quick lab where you
will create a container optimized
instance using the cloud console and a
CLI now remember you do not need a
Google cloud platform account or project
to do this lab an account project and
associated resources are provided to you
now let's get to it during the lab you
will learn to create a VM with the
container optimized OS and a docker
container using the CLI you'll also
learn to create a firewall rule to allow
access and can reach the default nginx
page using the external IP of the VM at
the end of this lab you'll be able to
create a compute engine instance with
the container optimized OS and a docker
container of your choice using the GCP
console and a command-line interface
since it comes with all container
related dependencies pre-installed
container optimized OS allows your
cluster to quickly scale up or down in
response to traffic or workload changes
optimizing your spend and improving your
reliability container optimized os
powers many GCP services such as
kubernetes engines and cloud sequel
making it Google's go-to solution for
container workloads quick labs is an
online hands-on lab library with more
than 150 labs on every cloud topic from
intro to expert level each lab helps you
learn a new skill in about 30 minutes
using google cloud when you're ready
use this link to take the lab we just
went through today and when you're ready
to sign up for GCP use this link to
apply a $300 credit to your account we
want to hear from you every week we'll
answer a question from our viewers so
let us know what's on your mind in the
comments below
[Music]
you